このあるエピソードがあります
このアーナンダ・セッティヒ
セッティヒっていうのは億万長者っていうことでね
いう人がいて 八十億の金を持っていた人でね
ものすごく吉でしたと
この人は そこで彼がもう億単位でお金があるんですけど
一円ぐらいでも使わないという
それはすごく自分の哲学なんですね
毎月毎月いる金持ちの親戚集めたら
会議でも言うのはそういうことです
金っていうのは一円使っても減るんだよと
それでは金持ちになれません
金持ちっていうのは増やす人であると
それで息子にはしっかり言うと
毎週一回教えてあげるんだと
その家の教訓は で その人はもうどんどん財産たまると
あの これ家ではね 置いておけないんだからね
もう昔は違いますからね
金やらね そういうものですからね
とにかく財産は金にして金にして
それでも家で置いておくわけにはいきませんし
どこかで保管しておくんですね
銀行も何もない世代でしたから
土地はいくらでもあるし
だから誰にも言わないで
どこかでものすごくでっかい穴を掘って
そこでもうきっちり置いて埋めておいて
わからないようにしておくんです
で 暗証番号はないんです
どこに埋めたかともさっぱりわからない
もうかなりの土地やら森やら持ってますからね
そこでもう大量になってくると
1箇所に埋めて また大量に溜まるとまた１か所
それでいくつかぐらい場所に
億単位の金をね 埋めておいたんですが
この人は突然死んじゃったんですね
そうすると ちゃんと年取って
もうボロボロになってゆっくり死ぬんだったら
息子に言うんですよ 覚えておきなさい
財産はああいう場所にあります
そちらはこう行って こうこちら曲がってこちら曲がって行ったら
こういうこういう印があるんだと
例えばもうちょっとした山があって
その山から東にもう 100歩ぐらいあるようなところで
なんとかあって そこでありますよと
そういうふうに言ってあげなくちゃいけないんです
それ言う場合でも たった息子だけにもう一人聞いてたら
もう財産なくなっちゃいますからね
それ言う前にもう亡くなり死んじゃったんです
だから 1円も他人にあげてはいけないと
使ってはいけないという
すごい貧乏な生活をしていたんだから
当然もういいところに生まれ変われるわけじゃないんですね
そこでこの人は 乞食の村で生まれたんです
乞食といっても カースト不可触民食のカーストで乞食しか認めてないんです
仕事は で それで物を乞うて生活する
そちらに生まれたら 妊娠した日からその家族にはもう食べ物はもらわなくなっちゃったと
このあげたことはないんだからね
もらえない ほとんどその部落のみんななんか貧乏になっちゃって
元々貧乏なんですけど
やっぱり仕事に行ったらみんな食べ物をくれたりするんだからね
それで生活しているんですよ
だから貧乏がさらに貧乏になったということなんです
それでもね 母親がとにかく妊娠したものだからね
産むんですけど 産んで子供見たら目やら耳やら鼻やらあるべきところにないんだって
そういう風に書いてますね
パーリのこのストーリーで
こういう目やら耳やらね
あることはあるんだけど
場所が違うんだと これなんか冗談交えて書いてますけど
ということはものすごいディフォルメっていうことでしょう
手足はあるんだけど ちゃんと吸い付くところではないんだと
タッタハッタチャパーダ
手足 アッキーニー目 カンナ耳
ナーサ鼻 ムカというのは口
ナヤターネアヘソン あるべきところにはなかったと
それぐらいもうディフォームで生まれて
なんか餓鬼道の餓鬼みたいに見えるんだと
それでも母親にはどうすることもできんだからね
まあ一応育てて で 子供を抱っこして乞食に行ったら何ももらわない
追い出されるんだと そうすると
いくら泣いたってしょうがなく
子供を置いておいて 母親だけ行ったら食べるものをもらうんだと
で 苦労して育てて いくらか自分で歩けるようになったところで
この国でね 定期的に乞食たちに布施する場所があるんだと
今ヨーロッパでもあるでしょう
このホームレスの人々に
教会とかいろんなボランティアたちが毎日もう朝ご飯やら昼ご飯
もう 3食を作って  1日 1000人ではなくて
100人とか 200人
300人とかにずっと配ってますね
だからそちらで食べたい人は朝早く行って順番に並んで並んでいれば
まあその人々には食べられる
もう酒飲んで夜遅くまで寝たバカたちには
次の日も食い物はないということになるんです
まあそんな感じで このそういうずっと毎日食べ物をあげるとあるんだから
あんたそちらに行って食べて生活しなさいと
自由にいろんなところに歩き回って乞食することはこの子には不可能
その子はもうそうやって歩きながら
この自分が前にいたお城ありましたから
そこら辺にも歩きながら来たんだと
まだちっちゃな小さい子供なんですけど
息子がもうあの家の次の億万長者になっていて
それでその子はもう先生で人間でしたからね
大体人間が死んで人間になったら過去は覚えているんです
それはすごく普通なことなんで
珍しいことじゃないんです
別な次元でいて 人間になったら
それをきれいさっぱり忘れるんですよ
で 思い出すきっかけないんです
でも人間に生まれることってすごく難しいんですよ
で ミャンマー タイでもスリランカでもね
そういう生まれて生まれ変わってるケースっていうのはもう結構あります
ちゃんと調べますけど
子供たちはその全てのケースの場合は
過去世はもう人間なんです
全部覚えてるんです 名前から何でもかんでも
場所とかね 何やっていたかとかね
まだ子供なのに 私にはもっともっと年上の子供がいるんだぞとか偉そうなことを言うんです
言うと調べて もういきなり会わせてみるんですね
いきなり会わせたらもうみんな知ってて
で それでああなるほど
まあこれはもうこの子言ってることはね
ちゃんとデータがあるっていうことになりまして
別な次元から来たらわからないんですね
例えば過去生で犬だったらね
人間に生まれたらもう綺麗に全部忘れてしまう
だからこの子もね まあ過去生は人間でしたからね
まああのお城に入ったら
ところに行ったら 何のことなく自分の家だからね
何のことなく入っちゃったんだと
普通おびえちゃっても入れませんしね
だから知らない土地でもなんとか入ろうと思って
あっち見てこっち見て
どこを行けばいいかと調べるとすぐバレちゃうでしょうね
これを何のことなく 堂々と道も何でもかんでも知ってるんだから
ずっと家の中まで入ったんだと
誰も気づかない それで家の中に入ったら
この孫たちがいるんですね
孫たちは見たことがない
もうかなりごっつい贅沢で育てられているんだから
こんなもうガキみたいなものって見たことはなくて
いきなりお化けを見たと思って叫んで大変なことになっちゃって
それで家の召使いの人々とかね
出てきて で 家の主人もこれ息子の見てね
なんていうこの不可触民族のガキがね
子供がどういうところに入ったのかと思って怒って
ものすごく殴って くったくた殴って
もうそのまま捨てちゃったんです
ゴミに捨てるところに
そこで死ぬでしょうと
まあ殺さな殺しますよ
だから子供だからどうしようもなく殺さなかったと思います
不可触民族の人は人の家の土地に入ったらもう昔厳しかったんです
今もかなり殴りますよ
インドでは すごいカースト制度っていうのは汚いんですよ
だからこの場合はもう殴りたい放題殴っちゃって
もう捨てちゃったと ゴミ箱のところ
ゴミの捨てるとゴミ捨て場に
それはお釈迦様が自分の神通力でね
あの出来事を知って アーナンダ尊者と
このゴミのところにね
人間捨てているんだからね
まあこれはやっぱり で
その子をそこから取ってもらって
持っていって もうお釈迦様っていうのはもう王家の人だからね
誰の家にも入れます で
一番上のカーストなんですね
特に釈族っていうのは
だからもうその人の家に入ってね
お釈迦様に断ることできんだからね
仏教ではなかったんですけどね
で お釈迦様みんな呼びなさいと
まあ宗教家がね 自分が殴って
もう死ねと言ってゴミ捨て場に捨てた子を持ってね
あんた何やらの怒ったってどうってことないんだからね
また法律は別ですからね
ということで もうどういうことかというと
なんかみんな自慢げに
あんた文句言うつもりですかっていう感じでみんな集めたんです
お釈迦様は人々を集めるということを聞いたら
周りの人々はほとんど仏教徒で在業だからね
みんなが入ってきて お釈迦様はこの息子にモーリヤという名前のついて
あんたね この子を知ってますかと
知らないでしょうと あんた知ってるはずですと言うんです
あなたはよくこの子を知ってるはずですと
なんということおっしゃるのか
初めて見たんだけど こんなにリフォームの人っていうのは
これはね あなたの父親はアーナンダだよと
えらい貴族の人がこんなこと言われると
不可触の民族があんたの父親だよって言うと
また子供でしょうにね
大変なことになるでしょう
そこで まあ大変なことになって
根拠ないことを何で言うのかと
そうあんたね 父親があんたに教えてない
何か秘密でもないの？と
聞いたら思い出して やっぱりすごい財産があったのに
どこにあったかわからない
ありますよと いつかのところに
お父さんがね 財産隠したっていうことは知ってますけど
その場所は知らないんだと
その前 すぐ突然死んじゃったと
ではその子供ね ちゃんとご飯食べさせてあげて
ちゃんと体綺麗にしてね
聞いてみたらどうですかと
そしたらちゃんとお腹いっぱいご飯食べさせて
きれいにしてあげて ちゃんと聞きなさいと
お父さんと呼んで でなきゃうまくいかないんだぞと
そうするとその人も自分を実子の父親呼ぶような言葉でお父さんが財産隠したところを教えてくれないんでしょうかと言うと
その子供は何もあまり言葉を喋らなかったみたいですけど
何のことなく指であの辺場所を見せたんです
そしたら掘ってみたら財産ですね
もうそこでまんまともう証拠済みですからね
で そこでそういうことやと
自慢げに生活するなよと
人間っていうのは 私の財産やと思ったこのこいつは今どうですかと
今金が 1個にも権利ないでしょうと
不可触 別な不可触民族のところに生まれている乞食ですからね
これ死ぬまで乞食で生活しなきゃいけないでしょうに
だからあんた方もね もうこれ私の財産
私の可愛い子供たちだとかね
ひどい目に遭いますよと
何一つも自分のものじゃないんだよという説教をしたんです
その出来事で それでやっとアーナンダ
アーナンダさんがの息子がね
怖くなってブッダの教えを信じることになりましたという話です
そこら辺で終了しましょう
またもう一つ偈に行っちゃうとね
どこまで行くかわからないんです
で まあ個だけで十分でしょうね
個だけでもかなり素晴らしい哲学でしょ
素晴らしい人生論なんですよ
これでは皆様もそれを覚えておけば何でも成功しますよ
いわゆるあるのは因果法則であって
ないのは自分だと それだけは覚えておくのは
自分がないということで生活してみるんです
そうすると いろんな物事を組み合わせるしかないんです
組み合わせたら いい結果がね
出てくる この怒ったりストレス溜まったりするのは自分がいると思ってる
思ってる時なんですよ
すごく疲れるんですよ
仕事でも何でもかんでも
自分がいると思っちゃうと
何か批判されると あれこれ言われると
もう嫌で嫌で嫌で もう仕事するのやめたくなるんですよ
だから初めからも私以外ないということであるのは因果法則
だけど何かあるんだからね
一応 それが単なる因果法則やと
思っちゃえば お釈迦様が言った愚か者というタイトルは
まあちょこっと  これはまあ後で上げますということに取り上げられることになります
でなきゃもうそのまま張った
張られたままで このタイトルが愚か者という
[咳]そういうことで頑張ってみてください
では どうもありがとうございます